let's say that this triangle right over
here is equilateral which means all of
its sides have the same length and let's
say that that length is s what I want to
do in this video is come up with a way
of figuring out the area of this
equilateral triangle as a function of s
and to do that I'm just going to split
this equilateral in two I'm just going
to drop it I'm just going to drop an
altitude from this top vertex right over
here this is going to be perpendicular
to the base and it's also going to
bisect this top angle so this angle is
going to be equal to that angle and we
showed all of this in the video where we
proved the relationships between the
sides of a 30-60-90 triangle well in a
regular equilateral triangle all of the
angles are 60 degrees so this one right
over here is going to be 60 degrees let
me do that in a different color this one
down here is going to be 60 degrees this
one down here is going to be 60 degrees
and then this one up here 60 degrees but
we just split it in two so this angle is
going to be 30 degrees and then this
angle is going to be 30 degrees and then
the other thing that we know is that
this altitude right over here also will
bisect this side down here so that this
length this length is equal to that
length and we showed all of this a
little bit more rigorously on that
30-60-90 triangle video but what this
tells us is well if this entire length
was s because all three sides are going
to be s it's an equilateral triangle
then each of these so this part right
over here is going to be s over two and
if this length is s over two we can use
what we know about 30-60-90 triangles to
figure out this side right over here so
to figure out what that what the actual
altitude is and the reason why I care
about the altitude is because the area
of a triangle is one half times the base
times the height or times the altitude
so if this is s over two the shortest
side the side opposite opposite the
stick opposite the 30-degree angle is s
over two then the side opposite the
60-degree angle is going to be square
root of three times that so it's going
to be square root of three s over two
and we know that because the ratio of
the sides of a 30-60-90 triangles a
30-60-90 triangle
the side opposite if the side opposite
the 30-degree side is 1 then the side
opposite the 60-degree side is going to
be square root of 3 times that and the
side opposite the 90 degree side is or
the hypotenuse is going to be 2 times
that so it's 1/2 square root of 3 to 2
so this is a shortest side right over
here that's the side opposite the
30-degree side the side opposite the
60-degree side is going to be square
root of 3 times this so square root of 3
s over 2 so now we just need to figure
out we just need to figure out what what
the area of this triangle is using area
is equal to area of our triangle is
equal to 1/2 times the base times the
height of the triangle well what is the
base of the triangle well the entire
base of the triangle right over here is
s so that is going to be s and what is
the height of the triangle well we just
figure that out it is square root of 3
times s over 2 and we just multiply that
out and we get C in the numerator you
get a square root of 3 times 1 times s
times s that is square root of 3 times s
squared and the denominator we have a 2
times a 2 all of that over 4 so for
example if you have an equilateral
triangle where each of the sides was 1
then its area would be square root of 3
over 4 if you had an equilateral
triangle where each of its sides were 2
and this would be 2 squared over 4 which
is just 1 so we'll just be square root
of 3 so we just found a generalizable
way to figure out the area of an
equilateral triangle